hong kong's real estate is consistently
ranked as the world's most expensive
it also ranks high for something else
inequality
the city's just recorded its hottest
week on record
so imagine what it's like to live here a
windowless cubicle measuring just over
two square meters
how long have you been here about about
eight years
for two hundred and seventy dollars a
month david lau rents a space just big
enough for a bed and his few belongings
it's on the sixth floor of a dilapidated
apartment block one of 14 partition
spaces that are created when normal
apartments are divided into minuscule
ones and where hygiene is a daily
struggle
inside is a must a quick test and a
drink our guide is local social workers
eli shan here helping to distribute
masks and kobit 19 test kits her
organization says that more than 220
000 people are now living this way
i last reported on this problem 13 years
ago what you're looking at are cages
not for animals
but people
back then miss c had already spent more
than a decade campaigning against
so-called cage homes she says not much
has changed since we last spoke that's
why we also request the government they
should increase the supply and then we
can irritate the caterpillar and should
be no more hit home yeah well the reason
why so many people live in these squalid
and often dangerous conditions is as was
the case 13 years ago because of hong
kong's acute public housing shortage
it's a shortage that means the waiting
time for such a home can be
up to 10 years
during a recent visit to hong kong
china's president xi jinping urged the
territory's new leader to make the issue
of affordable housing a priority
the local government has pledged to
build more than three hundred thousand
homes in the next decade something missy
says should have happened a long time
ago it's a shame in hong kong and we
hope we can improve it as soon as
possible and even the central government
concerns about the housing policy
but addressing the poverty hidden behind
this skyline will be a challenge
and one that former governments have
failed to resolve
adrian brown al jazeera hong kong